we are asked what
time
what time is it
so we first want to look at the hour
hand which is the shorter hand here and
see where it is pointing and it is
pointing right at seven so we are we
have just crossed the seventh hour so
the hour is seven and then we look at
the minute hand which is a longer hand
and this minute hand is pointing
straight up right at the 12. so this
means the 12 when you think of minutes
that's zero minutes past the hour and
then each number represents five more
minutes so this is right at seven
o'clock so this is right at seven
o'clock
let's check our answer let's do a few
more of these
where is the hour hand so this hour hand
you might say hey this looks closer to
eight than it is to seven but the key is
to realize that it has past seven and
hasn't gotten quite to eight yet so
we're still in the seventh hour so the
hour is seven notice his hands go in a
clockwise direction so it just past
seven hasn't gotten to eight yet so the
hour is seven and when we wanna think
about the minutes remember we start at
the at the top of the clock that's zero
minutes past the hour and then we can
count by fives all the way to where the
minute hand is so five so zero
five ten fifteen 15 20 25 30 35 40 45
we're 45 minutes past the hour so it's 7
45.
let's do a couple more
so where is the hour hand well it's
between the one and the two but the key
is to realize that it was going
clockwise it's past the one and it's
about to get to two so it's still in the
first hour so the hour is still one
and then the minutes we just have to
count from 12 but or count from zero by
five so 0
5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 45. it's 1 45 p.m
let's do one more
so here once again our hand is between
one and two so it's past one it hasn't
gotten to two yet so we're still in the
first hour
and then the minutes well we start at 12
that's 0 minutes past the hour 0
15. so it is 1
15. let's do even one more
so this one the hour hand is exactly at
two it's exactly at two
and the minute hand is exactly at twelve
so that means we're zero minutes past
the hour
so it's zero minutes past the hour